déjame escribir una matriz de dos por
dos sus elementos serán a b c d en
vídeos previos hemos aprendido cómo
encontrar la inversa de la matriz a la
fórmula que aprendimos nos dice que la
inversa de la matriz a será igual a 1
entre el determinante de la matriz a por
lo que se conoce como la adjunta de
nuestra matriz a la matriz adjunta se
obtiene cambiando de lugar la a y la t y
poniendo el negativo de b y c esta
fórmula sirve para matrices de 2 por 2
cuando tenemos una matriz de 3 por 3 es
un poco más complicado pero déjame poner
menos b y menos c
otra forma de pensarlo es que uno entre
el determinante de una matriz de 2 por 2
será a de menos bs
y eso multiplicado por la matriz adjunta
de a que solo es una palabra elegante
para esta matriz solo es la matriz de
menos b menos
todo esto es un repaso si no lo fue para
ti te encargó que lo revise en otras
secciones de khan academy lo que nos
preguntaremos en este vídeo será si
existe una situación en donde la matriz
o sea no invertible pausa el vídeo e
intenta pensar en un escenario o en un
conjunto general de escenarios en donde
la matriz no sea invertida bueno una
forma de pensar en una matriz no
invertible es que de alguna forma no
podamos realizar este cálculo ahora
observa sin importar cuál sea el valor
de a b c y d siempre podemos encontrar
la matriz adjunta pero cuál es la
situación en donde no seamos capaces de
calcular 1 entre el determinante bueno
será la situación en donde el
determinante de nuestra matriz a sea
igual a 0 hoy lo puedo escribir así el
determinante de nuestra matriz am sea
igual a 0
en esta situación observa no podemos
obtener 1
el determinante porque obtendríamos algo
indefinido por lo tanto podemos decir
que a es no invertirlo si y sólo si voy
a poner una flecha con dos puntas si y
sólo si el determinante de nuestra
matriz es igual a cero porque cuando el
determinante es igual a cero tendríamos
que dividir entre cero cuando buscamos a
la inversa
ahora exploremos un poco cómo se ve esta
situación si nuestro determinante es
cero entonces esta expresión debe de ser
igual a cero eso significa que aporte
menos b por ser es igual a cero o si
sumamos bc de ambos lados obtengo que a
de es igual
abc
y puedo manipular algebraica mente un
poco más esta expresión si divido a
ambos lados entre b y d
déjame hacer lo voy a dividir todo entre
b de estas desde cancelan estas b se
cancelan entonces obtengo que entrevé es
igual hace entrever por lo tanto podemos
pensar en la situación donde la razón
entre a y b es equivalente a la razón
entre c y d
ahora bien también podemos pensarlo de
otra manera si anoto mi ecuación
original a de igual abc podemos dividir
de ambos lados entre 6 déjame hacerlo si
divido a ambos lados entre 6 entonces
nos quedaremos con a en 13 es igual a b
/ de entonces la razón entre a y c es
igual a la razón entre b y d
en todas estas situaciones tendrás una
matriz no invertible porque el
determinante será igual a cero
bien veamos algunos ejemplos quiero que
me diga si las siguientes matrices son o
no invertibles tenemos primero la matriz
5 1 3 2
es esta matriz invertible pausa el vídeo
e inténtalo bueno el determinante de
esta matriz será 5 por 2 lo cual es 10
menos 3 por 1 lo cual de estrés entonces
10 menos 37
como 7 no es igual a 0 entonces sabemos
que la matriz es invertible podemos
encontrar su inversa
ahora que hay de esta otra matriz la
matriz 1020 250 500 es esta matriz
invertible
bueno el determinante de 10 20 250 y 500
serán 10 por 500 lo cual es 5.000 menos
20 por 250 lo cual también es 5000 por
lo tanto el determinante cero una vez
más si queremos encontrar su inversa
entonces calcularemos la matriz adjunta
y la multiplicaremos por uno entre el
determinante pero 1 entre 0 al no estar
definido por lo tanto esta matriz no es
invertible
espero que todo esto sea de ayuda nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo